why don't you just use the chat GPT app or cloud app on your phone? They can translate. Yeah, maybe for one turn or maybe two turns and it's gonna break. You're gonna say, how are you doing? And it's gonna answer you instead of translating halfway through. It does happen.
Welcome to ODSC's AIX podcast. This episode is
sponsored by ODSCAI West, the premier AI builders conference coming up this October 27th to 29th in San Francisco and virtually. Learn more at odsc.ai slash west and use the code
podcast for an exclusive 10% discount. All right. Hi, everybody. Welcome to the ODSC AIX podcast. I'm Jerry Wolf. I am guest hosting today, and I'm quite excited to do this. I'm quite
excited to guest host. Today, I'm going to introduce a newer friend of mine. We met at ODSC East. maybe six months ago, I think about six months ago. He was speaking on some topics and I was emceeing those sessions and we got to know
each other a little bit and we've stayed in touch and we're going to have a really cool conversation. I'm excited to introduce Mohamed Sultanea and he's quite an awesome guy. So with that said, I'm going to say, hi Mohamed, how are you? What's going on?
Talk to me. How's things today?
Hey Jerry, so good to see you and thank you for the invite and thank you for having me in the podcast.
Absolutely. Yeah. I know that last time we spoke, you are really just finishing like a lot of travel. You'd traveled a lot this summer. So maybe you can share a little bit about some of your travel and maybe a little bit of some highlights of those experiences.
Sure. I love to travel. And one of the perks of my job is that darn, I have to travel for conferences. I was just in Tokyo about a month ago and traveled around Japan, some remote areas in Hokkaido and very much
love that. And I have some collaboration in Helsinki at Aalto University. I had a short course. I was teaching agentic. AI and basically how to build prototypes for non-technical users and got to explore
Helsinki a little bit. I have some collaboration with University of Helsinki. So I have been going to Finland a few times this year. And what else? I was in California just a couple of weeks ago for some other, another conference. But before that,
earlier in the summer, we were in Europe for just travel, no conferences. So we do travel for not work related stuff too. And that's, I really enjoy. And one of the things I would like to talk about is one of the apps I made motivated by my travels, which was a
translation app and related to agentic AI. We can get to that anytime you team appropriate. I would love to talk about it as well.
Yeah, that sounds great. I think one of the things that's, I think, very interesting to the potential audience or the audience, as well as I think all of us, meaning you and I and those in our space, is the transition that is
happening into the agentic AI space. Right. So our mental models are changing. Our way of thinking through how we solve problems is changing. We're looking at model performance in a different way. We're looking at how
things flow and filter in a different way. And I know for the work that I do, I'm kind of on the leading edge of certain things, but you're certainly on the leading edge of many things. And that's one of the reasons I wanted to talk with you during this podcast today. So, yeah, if
you want to start talking about the translation app. Let's start talking about it and give us some insight about what it is and how it works. And then who knows, maybe I'll just kind of prod a little bit to kind of get some more detail from you about some of the internal workings and some of the
problems you had maybe in developing them.
Sure, absolutely. Let me take a step back for a second. I just wanted to say, obviously, as you mentioned, AI is transforming everything that we do. And I'm an educator in my classroom. I teach programming for a big part of what I teach is data science
and data analytics. All of this is changing. The way we work is changing and the way we learn is changing. We have to adjust very rapidly. And arguably, a lot of sectors, including education, are trying to play the game of cash up. And
there are big changes coming our way. And the way I look at it is the productivity gain that we are getting here is really not, at least for me personally, I find myself working more hours, even though I'm more productive, but I'm
glued to my, well, at least I was glued to my computer and trying to have these conversations and have guide my agent and manage my agents to do the work I want them to do. But in this year, 2026, I've tried to
step back and see how I can have meaningful changes in my day-to-day life that AI can bring. And this is also in line with my efforts trying to build AI for good kind of applications and where it can
have impact on accessibility, on equal opportunity, equity, and things like that. And translation has been one of them on top of my mind. And I have several motivations, but one of them is my own travels. I wanted to see... how I can
utilize these AI agents that do so wonderfully. My laptop, they're able to translate very seamlessly and bring it to my phone in a way that I can very quickly launch. So that was my motivation. And I had already started on the iPhone app earlier this year,
which we can talk about that as well. But I thought, okay, I am now able to develop... iPhone applications, even though I'm not a software developer. I am, as you know, I'm a physicist by training. I have been coding most of my life
since I was very young, but I never worked as a developer. I don't know much about front end and the applications. However, I understand the infrastructure. I understand the backend, the security and all of
those things. I'll give it a try. And I was able to build an application for myself. Just for me, I'm not trying to launch a startup here.
What you just said actually is so important. You just said, I thought I'd give it a try. That, maybe that line or that statement is now available to anyone, right? Like anyone can say, all they need to do is say, let me just give it a
try and they can build it. Whatever that is. Like whatever that piece is or whatever that app or tool or aspect of their life, right, that they want to automate or make easier, right? I also appreciate what you said about, yeah, AI
has made us more productive for sure. But it's also like, just like you said, like I'm glued much more and I'm trying to figure out my own ways, right, to let go and allow the agentic aspect to happen. And
it's a continual effort, right? It's a continual effort. So I appreciate what you said right there. Let's just give it a try. Like, why not? And see what happens. So yeah, so continue. I'm excited to hear more.
Yes, of course. It comes with the listeners should take it with a big grain of salt because in many aspects, the AI is untested territory, uncharted territory. And I like to also talk about a little bit about companionship. This is
a recent paper came out and that's an area I've been really worried that people turning into these apps, seeking mental health support and this study has no positive news. Exactly, exactly. These apps are capable of doing
anything on the surface, but they lack some infrastructure in terms of the thing you want them to do. And if you don't know how to build that infrastructure, you're building a shallow house that the first wind is going to collapse. And we have to be careful with that. And
the era of personal applications is here, but also it could mean that your personal application that you're building, if it's not hosted securely, you're going to expose your personal data and you're going to jeopardize your privacy and all of this. So we
should be very mindful of this. I don't want to discourage people to go and try it out. But if you have... the privacy and security in mind, you can ask your AI agent to help you to run the appropriate tests and making sure at
least you're not exposing that tool to the whole world, right? And it is just sitting on your device and for you. With that aside, my first try was I've been building a lot of voice agents lately. And I even, one of the voice agents
I made was for my slide deck that be a live translator. And it worked very nicely. And I thought, okay, this took me maybe a couple of hours with the knowledge I had already around how to build these voice agents with a knowledge base and with a
basically a pipeline that it actually understands what has been said so far and then translate in context. So I thought maybe I can apply this to the app. Yeah, explain that a little
bit more. Yeah, explain a little bit more of the background of that because I'm obviously aware of that because you use that same type of voice agent back at ODSC in Boston. But for the listeners or watchers, give us a little bit of an
idea of what that mental model is and what that looks like.
So the current existing apps that I have experimented with, or when it comes to translation, they are very much literal. And as we understand, language is not literal. You cannot just open a dictionary and start translating. And these apps are a
little bit better. These models behind them are a little bit better than that, but they don't operate in the full context that what you have said so far. If you now say it. What does this it mean in this context compared to
if you have the whole window? So the context is very important. The other aspect that is important is how do you want this translation to land? Is it in a formal setting and or is it a casual conversation? Because that's when those
eerie things happen. The other side of the conversation might say, I kind of get it, what it said, but it's very funny. I've never heard anyone using those terms. because it's not translating in context. It's not understanding the deeper level
contextual meanings behind the whole overall conversation. So with the LLMs, with the modern LLMs, if you provide the right context, these large language models are able to infer from that and provide a smooth
translation that kind of makes sense. If I use an idiom in English, and I'm translating it to, I don't know, let's say Finnish, then it will try to find an equivalent idiom in Finnish language as opposed to translating word by word, which will sound funny
in that language if that doesn't exist.
Very cool. Okay, so you built this translation app and tell us how it helped you or tell me how it helped in your travels. So from Tokyo to Finland to, and we'll say... I may be
politically incorrect to say this, but to the foreign land of California too. So I'm from California, so I can say that. Anyway, yeah, tell us a little bit about some of what you found when using your
translation app.
Yeah, I didn't unfortunately try to translate to Valley accent for me, but... But it was most helpful, I would say, in Japan. As soon as you step out of Tokyo, or even in Tokyo, I came across situations that
I was very happy that I had this app in my possession. And the very first, actually not the very first, but one of the scenarios that was really wonderful. was we went to this small bar. They're called Kaya. These
are bars that if you're sitting four or five people in it, it's going to feel cramped. They're very small, very cozy, very cute, and oftentimes hard to get to because they don't have a lot of seats. And these two older ladies, they are the bartenders
and they own the place. Possibly they live upstairs. I'm not sure. But we got in and ironically, that morning we had flown from Finland to Japan and the other three people sitting in the bar with us, it's a family from Finland. And-
Can you just by
coincidence?
Five points, complete coincidence. And they couldn't believe we were in Finland that morning. They spoke very fluent English. So that was not a problem. The problem was the ladies that owned the bar, they didn't speak any English. We were able to communicate enough to order what we wanted to order. But
beyond that, one of the reasons I love to travel is to connect to people. And I wanted to be able to connect even at the surface. just say, this was very delicious or the few words that we later learned, but not on our first day. So I was able to take out
the app halfway in our stay at that place and said a few things to this lady. And then she said things back and I was able to make her laugh. And then she responded back with something funny. And all of us were laughing. All of a sudden, I find all five of us,
plus the two ladies, the owners, we're all laughing out loud. Something that was not possible without it. We would not be able to, I could order beer, that's it. And I could say, thank you. But
we
were able to connect. And so many other stories that I don't think a Google Translate would have been able to accomplish. So I thought, okay, I'm going to try to fix some of the issues. Because at this point, it was just sitting on my phone as a developer and not on App
Store. But as we speak, it has been reviewed by Apple. I think by the time this podcast comes out, the app should be available. in the app store and people can give it a try.
Awesome. I'd love to hear more about like some of the technical issues you had, maybe from the data science side or from the data ingestion or voice ingestion and just how you handled the speech to text and then text back to speech, or maybe explain a
little bit about that for those that may not have a background in what's happening under the hood with voice agents.
Absolutely. So as you said, there is a full cascade pipeline that you can take the speech, translate it to text, give it to LLM, get the text back, and then bring it back to speech. And for a lot of the pipelines, that's the route
I go. For the translation app, I thought that the lag that this pipeline will cause, that's going to make the flow unnatural. I want it to be very natural. I wanted to have an app that feels like someone fluent is sitting next to me and is translating for me. And we all
perhaps have been there that someone translates for us. And you kind of can have a semi-natural conversation there. You can basically be in the flow. You can make each other laugh and basically have a meaningful conversation as opposed to
just sending a letter back and forth and wait for a little bit to come back. So that was one. One of the motivations behind it that I switched to a voice-to-voice model. So the voice-to-voice models say there's that step from translating to
text is completely skipped. The model hears the voice and all the information in the voice, for instance, it can detect if you're speaking fast or if there's any emotion attached to what you're saying. And in the translation, it can use that information and convey
the message with the emotion attached. So that's one motivation. The second motivation is the smaller lag that these models can actually, sometimes I have to inject some artificial lag so it feels natural. Yeah. So we have
an opposite problem that it could be really fast. As soon as you stop talking, it starts translating and it might feel like, oh, did you actually even think about it? Because for us, if I ask you a deep question and you start immediately answering me, it gives me a signal that you didn't actually think
about my question, right? So when he takes his cues, so I've added some artificial lag there. So it is still fast, but the kind of human level that you would expect someone to take your sentence or few
sentences, take a moment, maybe, you know, a third of a second and then start translating.
So what you're saying is, I think that's why my wife feels like I don't listen to her because I don't have an artificial lag that is happening when she says something. Yeah. I mean, I'm very immediately just jumping in and saying, no,
it should be this way or whatever I'm saying. So that's interesting. So this artificial lag, how did you evaluate that? How did you build? I would assume that you started to evaluate that just by listening and just interacting. And then did you build any
evaluations after that? That's super interesting. I'd like to hear more.
So one fascinating thing about making an app for yourself is that you are the test user as well. Like every night on our trip, especially in Japan, because that's where I use the app the most, I am back at the hotel before bed. I'm giving a long prompt to my
cloud code agents to work on the issues I found that day. And I am the evaluator as well. It has to work for me and also for the opposite side as well. It was very important for me to understand informally without surveying the user. How was
this conversation? Because you can tell if that person wants to continue that conversation or not. If they find the UI intuitive enough because they have to press a button. There is a hands-free option. The hands-free option struggles in the noisy area because it can pick up the conversation at the table
next to you and so on. So you want to make sure that the UI is friendly, not just for yourself, because that's where I don't trust myself. I am building it. I want this UI is going to be used by people who've never seen this app before, most likely,
right? It's not that I'm going to be using it with the same person they're going to get used to. So it should be intuitive enough that on the first use, first try, people can jump in. So these are the kind of cues that I build, I use to develop and make the app better just to
work better for me. And that lag is just my own intuition. If I'm making a company out of this, I will, of course, need a bigger test group and understand people, right? So that's not what I'm doing here. And I should also say other technical
things that may be of interest to you and your audience, the noise cancellation, the feedback that because it's on the speaker by default, you're not using headphones. So these are the things that you have to take into account. Also the context, even
though it's a voice-to-voice model, you're able to provide the context of the conversation. What has been said so far, summarize that. So I have another LLM working on the side that there are several models involved. If I wanted to expand a little bit, you have a
technical audience, so I think I can. So the voice-to-voice is just the surface translation, is what the other person hears. There is a voice-to-text model in parallel to voice-to-voice that is transcribing. So all the transcription is being shown to the
users, both sides. So this user sees the bottom half of the screen, the opposite side sees the other half, the translation. And then all of this context is being passed every single turn to the voice-to-voice model. So the voice-to-voice model
can know what has been said so far and then what does that particular word mean in that context. And then every turn, once the translation is spoken to the other side and the transcription has been created,
another LLM kicks in, translates the translation back to the original language. So the speaker can actually validate. Maybe I'm talking to a border officer and they just ask me where I'm planning to go or if I have anything to
declare. I want to make sure I am giving the right accurate answer, not something that could put me in handcuffs. Or in other cases too, right? We want to make sure that our conversation is what we meant it to be, as opposed to that is being
mistranslated for us. So that validation was very important for me. It adds to the cost a little bit. However, for anything that is sensitive, I always check. And if it's incorrect, I'm like, hold on a second. I try it again. At least you have one way without having a native
speaker that speaks both languages next to you. And that functionality acts as a validator layer.
Love it. I think that's great. What's the voice to voice model that you use and what are, what were the other models that you used?
So for the voice to voice, I am using, I've been updating the model as the new ones come out. Right now is the GPT real time 2.1. And I think it's the state of the art voice to voice model at the moment.
Yeah.
and with the highest accuracy, highest quality, and price-wise also. There is a mini version of that that I, because I'm releasing it to public, I wanted the user to have control. So if you want to lower the cost by a factor of eight, you can switch to the mini
version. The lag also drops. So that's when you actually need artificial lag because the mini version is so fast that you would need some artificial lag. And then for the other models, it's a combination of OpenAI and Tropic. APIs. This speed is very important
here because you want the validation shown right away, not too late. So I've been testing with different models and of course, accuracy is also important. So I've landed with some of the LEMs and this is where I don't think open source could work, but
not on device because oftentimes you're going to have problem with the lag. Yeah,
you lose the reliability in this case because the open model, the open weighted models aren't, they haven't built out that. The frontier labs still have the lead. They're always going to have the lead, I think, but they have the lead significantly in that voice or in that
speed arena with the reliability, right? So they've still got that. All right, so you've got the voice-to-voice, you've got voice-to-text, you've got the LLMs doing, you've got a validator LLM that's sending the output back so you can check
it. And how much did you have to deal with parallelization and concurrency and making sure that was all kind of managed so that the side effects were properly going to the summary? agent we'll call the summary agent and did you have did you have
separate did you hard code that like was it programmatic or did you build agents into those lem uses in other words did you have a summary agent validator agent yeah
yeah it is all hard coded because i want those things are the things i want to happen every single time and the safeguards are also hard coded One of the challenges I had initially, you asked earlier about challenges, was the model. Even if I had the right prompt, I would say, hey,
Jerry, how are you doing? And then it will respond back, my name is not Jerry, but I'm doing well. I'm like, no, your job is to translate. Right. So I started, even it had the prompt, it would make those mistakes.
So I started to hard code some guardrails that if the translation is not happening, the audio doesn't come out and it'll, it'll basically try again and, you know, maybe another half a second lag and it's not going to be that noticeable. But yeah, so most of those things are
hard coded. There is a feature I added to the app that just to press a button, it comes out of the translation mode and becomes an assistant. And that's where it has some automation, some tools access, including the web search. So let's say you and
I are speaking about something and then you say, oh, you know, we are connecting. You're like, oh, did you watch the game today? What's, did you know, what's the score? Have you checked? I'm like, no, I haven't. And you can just switch to assistant and just ask for the score, ask for the weather forecast for tomorrow. And then it can, the
assistant can operate in either languages and you can come back to the translation right after. So the assistant would know the context of the conversation up to that point. So when you ask a question, it can kind of connect it up.
You know what I love about that? And I'd like to see this if you've got it ready. I'd love to see a little screen share of what you've built. That would be really cool. But what I like about what you just said, and now you may not be a marketer, but what you just said is
very marketing. In other words, you just created a stickiness to the app because it's not just translation, but it can go out, get information for you as a typical... you know, chat bot,
grab that information with the tool calls, right? Bring it back in and put it back into the conversation so that you don't have to leave the app. And when you do that, that makes it sticky. And when it makes it sticky, you've just found a nice little way to keep the user inside that
ecosystem. So you may be a professor, but maybe you're a marketer as well, just kind of,
you know,
underneath it. But I love that.
How did you think? You know, part of my job as a professor is sales, right? I have to sell ideas to my students and I have to convince them why this old way of doing you want to change and why the new thing I'm teaching you is worth it. But, you know, really
what I've tried here is what I wanted to have. If such an app existed today, I wouldn't have gone out of my way to create it. One might say, okay, why don't you just use the ChatGPT app or Cloud app on your phone? They can translate. Yeah, maybe for one
turn or maybe two turns and it's going to break. You're going to say, how are you doing? And it's going to answer you instead of translating halfway through. It does happen. And I just want to have a robust system, but it's simple. Just press a button so anyone can use, including myself. I was my
first user, but I also thought this agent can do a lot more than translation, right? Maybe you have a question, forget about the web search, but you're thinking about like maybe an idiom that you've heard. in this other language that you're trying to connect
to, but you cannot remember and the user cannot, the other side cannot help. You're like, okay, let's switch to assistant and ask about this idiom. So you have like a third person there that can jump in any time and become an assistant as opposed to a translator, because these models are so
powerful. They know all of this surface level knowledge in any field. So it's just a button to bring it into conversation.
Muhammad, you said something that is, again, so I think so very relevant. I experience it all the time where someone says, well, why can't you just do that in cloud? In other words, you know, I build a system or I build a tool. And then the question is, why can't you just do it in cloud? Well, yeah, you
can, but you're going to have a lot of problems. And yeah, maybe for one turn, but in my world, I do a lot of like document ingesting. So let's say you're ingesting all these documents and document 443 errors out or there's a problem with it. And then
what do you have to do? You have to now figure out from Claude what happened and then re-ingest all these documents. Instead, you just have a system. So you built, in this case, a system around the translation. And yeah, Claude is powering it, right? With OpenAI
or ChatGPT and other models, it's powering it. But you've built the system. And I think building the system is the human value to all of this, right? It's where the human comes in and says, we can design this so that it's easy for the user.
And like you and I have talked about before, right? Then it keeps the cognitive load of the human where it needs to be instead of where it shouldn't be. But that's taxing,
right?
100%. I'm 100% with you. And that's one of my motivations here. I've talked more about in the other app that I want to remove this stickiness between me and my computer. I want to be out in the world. What I want to use is these models in a way that do things that
weren't possible before. I am not, I don't know, the president of country XYZ that anywhere I travel, I'm going to have a... great world-class translator next to me. But I can, now I can, I can have that in my pocket. And by the way, before I
share my screen and show you the app, I also wanted to say a huge shout out to ODSC, actually, ODSC East, where you and I met in, I think, March or April. I was having lunch with a group of speakers in the speakers
lounge, and we were talking about voice agents, and I was talking about my... talk that I was about to give. And one of the other speakers at the table, the conversation was switch to translation. And I said, I've been considering to make such an app. And he said,
please do, please do. I will be your first user. So once the app comes out, I'm going to send him a message on LinkedIn and thank him for his suggestion and his motivation, because I really enjoyed using it myself.
I love that. I love that story. And not a plug to ODSC, but you're totally right. There's something very special about ODSC and the people that we meet there. There's a certain level of energy. There's a certain level of sharing and like,
hey, what are you working on? And let's talk about it. And everybody's excited to talk and to listen and to participate. And it's kind of rare because a lot of conferences that at least I've attended... and gone to and spoken at and exhibited at.
Many of those conferences are just, they're all about vendors, right? It's kind of vendor-centric instead of community-centric or developer engineering specific, right? Just about the people, right? So that's great. I love that, Mohamed. Love it.
That's great.
And their people are open. And I think ODSC has created this culture of openness and perhaps one of the few companies that they claim and they have the name open in their name and they remained open. I'm just going to leave it at that.
Okay, that was a nice little twist of the knife, right? That was a nice little twist. We all know what's going on. We all know who you're talking about. So yeah, that was great. Love it. Yeah, share it. I'd love to see it.
All right, let me bring it up. Hopefully things will work out, especially with the... So I'm going to bring up the audio and try to share the audio. This is basically a developer version. I'm sharing my screen right now. And tell me if you can
see. Okay. So it's right now set to from English to Ukrainian because a lot of the wonderful folks that help this podcast speak Ukrainian. But do you want me to change to another language? What do you want?
Yeah, maybe to Spanish. That's kind of a more ubiquitous.
So currently 73 languages are. And by the way, let me also, the name of the app, even though I think by the time this podcast comes out, this should be available on App Store. If enough people were interested, I will also, at this
point, it's so easy to convert to Android app as well. But it's called Allowed and Allowed Live Translator. And let's go ahead and try. So first, initial connection. The default, I have set it not to be on hands-free mode,
but that's an option. I'm going to say... Thank you again for having me at this wonderful podcast. It is such a pleasure to be here. Okay, so now this is the heard back. Thank
you again for having me on this wonderful podcast. It's a real pleasure to be here. So I said it's a great pleasure, but I said it is such a pleasure. The translation of translation is it's a real pleasure. So the meaning is there. and i'm happy with it i'm not
gonna interrupt and say no no that's not what i said because the reality is you lose some of the context in translation right and that's especially as you're talking about deeper conversations if you're talking about poetry forget about it right but this is a
mean to connect people in a way that may not possible before
So this is really cool right now. There's a couple of things that I'm noticing that are pretty awesome about this. One, I love that the text on the other side is upside down, you know, to you or, you know, to the to the initial speaker. And that creates like a really cool situation if you're at a
table, right? You're at a table, you're at dinner, you're talking and you're meeting new people. And it's put the phone down. You're at the bar wherever you're at. And it's. easy to read from each person. So very great, very cool UI on that. The second thing is the green dot
on the herd back. So does that green dot, if it isn't as accurate as you would expect, does it go to yellow or red?
Yes. Yes. Okay. I believe yellow is the color. Yes.
Okay. Yes. So that's cool. So that gives you a nice visual of, okay, maybe there's an issue here.
Yeah.
right? Coming back. And then I loved how fast, just like you said earlier, I loved how fast the her back piece came back after the translation. So you've got some great parallelization happening here. And then the other part of it is that you can kind of learn the other
side of the language because now you can see what the other person is seeing with the Gracias de Nuevo, like below. So love that. Like that's really cool. Okay. Let's do one to Japanese. Let's go to Japanese.
Yeah, actually, I was going to say one of the things I was trying to do in Japan was to improve my Japanese with the app, especially with the assistant feature. So let me try. I'm going to embarrass myself. I'm going to try this side. Arigato gozaimasu.
Thank you very much.
And then let's say I can, and you know, the haired back is also switched here. And by the way, I could change this orientation. Let's say if you're sitting next to me, I can have it so both are facing down. Very cool. So you can very easily change that.
But you can also type with its own keyboard. So if there is an error here, you can actually edit the error. So or you can just type from scratch and the keyboard is going to be based on the language. I could do the same thing here, which is different than my phone
keyboard. But let me switch to assistant now. Can you please help me to pronounce this phrase correctly? Absolutely. Just share the phrase you'd like to pronounce and I'll help with the correct pronunciation. I'm learning some Japanese. I want to say
thank you when I'm very happy with the service. Nice choice. The standard and polite way to say it is arigato gozaimasu. That's best said like arigato gozaimasu. Keep the go a bit soft and light and finish
with a gentle su. Great job. Arigato gozaimasu. That was a fantastic attempt. It sounded
great. For a smoother flow,
you can say arigato gozaimasu with a light pause between arigato and gozaimasu. Well done. Arigato gozaimasu. Very nice. You've got the tone. Just make it a bit smoother. Arigato gozaimasu. Hard to
please. Make it gentle and flowing. And one more feature, which I learned from another app that actually I don't have it, but... One of the fellow travelers pointed to me is a camera. So if I'm at a restaurant, I
can point the camera. Right now, this is sitting on my Mac, so it wouldn't work, but I could point my camera at a menu and it can talk about the menu to me or a sign while I'm walking down the street.
Yeah. Yeah. That's very cool. Okay. Talk to me about, I love the UI. Very, very cool. The languages that you've chosen or that are available and the keyboards that are available, the keyboard. Tell us, tell me about the programmatic aspect of
building out the keyboard, both maybe from the UI itself and what needed to happen on the backend to bring that in. Yeah.
So the available languages, they're all based on my limit is whatever the voice-to-voice model I'm using right now. So I would love for these frontier models to expand to more languages and more dialects. That's one of the limitations. The
keyboard itself, that was a challenge because you can't just have any keyboard you want. You have to install them separately. So this was a task. I'm glad you brought it up because I think this was one of those single prompt tasks that took over 10, 15 hours with multiple agents. And
I wanted to develop these keyboards, have tester agents, a user experience, all of this by AI. This is the part that I don't have the budget for, to go out and hire at least one person for one of these languages to test. So I'm kind of hoping for
the best at this point. As a personal app, I haven't, I speak Persian, so I was able to verify the Persian keyboard. It had some issues. I was able to ask for those issues to be fixed. It wasn't wrong, but it was just using the Arabic
keyboard, which is different. There are four letters in Persian language that, but you could still get those letters by holding down a key. key and some of the keys and get those letters. But for someone who you just met at the airport, you're going to have a three minute
conversation. They are not going to have the time to figure that out. So you kind of miss opportunity. So I had a follow-up or two follow-up prompts that was fixed, but I'm sure there are other issues that requires verifiers, people who are native speaker.
Awesome. So it took, the actual agentic flow took about 10, 15 hours to build out the keyboard feature, right? With multiple prompts back and forth. And yeah, that's a really cool feature. And I see the complexity and it makes
sense that it took that. From my perspective, it makes sense that it took that long because there's a lot of complexity to that. Everything is on device except for the calls to the voice-to-voice and the voice-to-text, right? Everything else is on device.
There is a backend that is maintaining all of the transcripts. So if I wanted to go back to the chat history, I have the transcript history and I can see I test all sorts of things. So I can
see that I have the cost also is a store. You can go around. This is all being stored in the backend database, but Otherwise, yes, the rest is going to be on device on the API calls. I should also say the
API calls are taking place in a secure way. I'm not sending my OpenAI API key to the app. I'm not exposing that. So I'm minting these tokens for that session. So that is all happening in the backend. And that's why when I
press this button, it takes about seven, eight seconds for the connection
to take place. Yeah. What backend are you using or what service are you using?
Oh, I'm using Supabase these days. I love it. And most of my projects are on free Supabase. So once I, you know, if the app grows, then I'm going to start paying because you would need a bigger server. But for one person, this is perfect.
Yeah, you know, I've never used Supabase. I mean, I know a lot of people that use it. I come from the background where I just, I'll go directly to and build the database instance, whether it's a SQLite or Postgres or something else. But Supabase, they've grown a ton and a lot of
people use them. And for building an app, at least an initial, even a production app, Supabase really has been the go-to choice. I just have never used it, but I've always heard that it's easy and very easy to interact with. Very
cool. And one of the features of Superbase, if I can maybe bridge this conversation with the other app that I've been mentioning, one of the nice features of Superbase is the row level security that is built in by default. And each user has access to
their own rows, which is you would think all the apps are going to have it, but This other app that I'm actually a lot more excited because I'm now using it multiple times a day is an interface to all of my agents that are doing quote unquote productivity work for me. Like one of them
scrapes the news, one of them scrapes the recent research, and they all generate these audio files for me in format of a podcast or debate, and they just populate my app. And one of the things I learned this morning was, I think the news is from yesterday or two days ago,
this person in Australia was using his cloud chat, maybe co-work, I'm not sure which interface, was asking, hey, can you get me in this gym class? And apparently the gym class was full. In order for the AI model to
squeeze him in, it was able to figure out the API behind the app of the class reservation. It was open. It kicked out one of the people who was registered, opened the space, and then placed this guy in. And this
person felt bad and said, I don't want it. Can you reverse? And said, let me see. Oh, wasn't able to reverse that. And so the class and made it to the news brings us to maybe if you want to talk about AI safety and
risks, that's another topic that I've been really concerned about lately. But just because they weren't using proper security features around their API. And I think with SuperBase, the defaults are pretty good. You still need to tighten that up.
Yeah, great story. I had not heard that story, but you know, that's, it does, right? These agents can expose and they do expose, right? All the vulnerabilities that we fail to create. All these vulnerabilities that we create by failing to really
understand what those vulnerabilities are when we write them. Even the best software engineers, right? Have that problem, right? It's... The most, it reminds me of the mythos, like when mythos came out or before mythos came out and Anthropic just gave it to, you know, the
CrowdStrikes of the world, right? The four or five big companies, because even the CrowdStrike engineers missed some things that had problems, right? Exactly. So yeah, that's very interesting. Yeah. If you want to talk about safety, whatever you'd like to talk about. I love
this. Let me ask one more question about the translation app, about Allowed. How long did it take? to, we'll say, build V1 or whatever your version is that you think was ready enough to send to Apple, right? To go through that. How
many weeks? What are you looking at there?
So good question. This is my V1 that I've sent to Apple. It's scheduled to be released today. V1 that I was able to use on my travels. That took about maybe four weeks of sporadic... At
any given time, I'm working on more than 15 projects in parallel. I manage a lot of people. I have a lot of wonderful people that I work with and I am collaborators and I don't have full time on any given project. So these are basically my
vacation time, you know, an hour a day and just giving the right prompt or at least what I think is the right prompt. And I try to embed the four and full loop, the validation I... That's one of the reasons it takes so long because the same
environment, the same app that you see, it's in a simulator that another agent brings up and plays around with it and tries to understand if things are working or not. But I would say like maybe four weeks, very, very part-time, but it took maybe another 10 more weeks to get
to a point that I'm willing to share it publicly without embarrassing myself.
So here's what I'm hearing from that. I have similar experiences. When you go to YouTube, right, and you see the latest and greatest and someone, you know, a new model comes out. So what does somebody do? Builds a game, right? One shot's a game, right? And they can one shot a game and
it looks really cool and it's done in five hours, 10 hours, whatever. But there's a lot of work that goes into building an app that has real value. And I just kind of think about AI in this way now, which I think goes back to the
earlier part of about when we build AI or when we build things, AI gives us the ability to build anything, right? But it doesn't mean that that anything is... our thing, right? Like, you know, so maybe your first iteration, it built
it and it built it great, but it still wasn't what you wanted. And that takes weeks and weeks and weeks of effort just on the feature side of it. Forget the backend and security and the non-functional requirements, just getting the functional requirements because we don't know
what we want until we see it. And then we're trying to figure it out. And then we may change a little bit about what we think we want, right? It's like, When I'm interviewing potential clients about whatever projects they want to work on, they think they want A, but they really want A prime or B prime or B or
whatever they want. It's something different. So that's the cool thing about AI now, right? Is being able to say, build this, and then you get to be creative by twisting and turning the knobs and figuring it out. But it takes time. There's no shortcut.
I'm so happy you brought it up. The app you're looking at probably took me two to 4,000 prompts. I didn't count, but that's my best estimate. It takes a long time and it takes a lot of energy in terms of AI cost and AI
energy, another discussion. But maybe I think the other app that might be the audience here, probably the most relevant to this other app, which is basically an interface for the AI agents that are working behind the scene.
Okay, yeah,
let's take a look. I think a lot of people have been trying different agents. So I'm going to share my screen again with a new app. So a lot of people try the, what do they call, OpenClaw and Hermes and... If they don't
want to go full on another environment, maybe Codex and Cloud Code and anti-gravity and so on. But it remains so they can do things. Like at ODSC and other conferences, I've seen people having their AI agent to, I don't know, order lunch
for them or do other things for them autonomously. That works most of the time. I wanted something that works all the time. And it's in a wrapper that is easy for me to access. And this app, if other one was two to 4,000 prompts, this
is probably like four to 6,000 prompts. I spent a lot more time with my first app. This one is available on App Store right now. It's called Clickbox with a K. Unfortunately, when you type in kickboxing apps are the ones that come first. So
you have to click on the small blue button below it and say, yeah, actually I meant Clickbox. to come up. There are so many apps these days, but the idea was very simple and I didn't find anything that will do this in a phone. So the first
idea is having like a to-do list that I can ask my AI agent to manage. For instance, my AI agents now, I'm brave enough. This is only Claude. I trust the company. They have access to my calendars and all of my
emails. So I wanted to go through and create to-do lists based on the emails I need to respond. Potentially, if it's a straightforward answer, draft a response for me to review because it can go back and look at the history. It can see my
tone, how I have responded before. Give me a draft and I can edit and... So that part was the first iteration of this app. The way it works, you go to the setting and then you generate a here, bring your own agent and API key. You pass this
API key to your agent, wherever the agent is. The document here will teach your agent how to interact with this app. Okay. That's fine. But I want it to do more for me. One of the other. ideas I had was I get a lot of ideas here and
there, and I want to be able to take a screenshot, write down a quote. Like for instance, here, I could write down a quote and I say, let's see, what did, what did Jerry teach me today? If I wanted to quote you exactly, you'd say
use, I'm just going to put something here, use safely. Okay. Not your words, but I can, you know, I can put Jerry and I can say, I'm preparing for a keynote speech. I'm writing a book chapter and a book. I can
maybe, I want to talk about it, talk about AI safety in my keynote. So I can tag it here and capture. And then I have my AI agent to go every night and take and capture this idea, put it in a document related to
the topic. So if I go back two months later, I have all of these bits at conferences that while I'm browsing the internet and so on, I have captured. Okay, good. But not that revolutionary. I think there are individual apps you could do parts of these. But the part
that I am super excited and I've been using it in about a week or so, it just became ready, is the debrief. The debrief is the same idea. Your AI agent has access to your information. You don't have to provide that information to the app. The app is just, this
app is just a vehicle to deliver to you what your agent is passing along. So your agent has access to all sorts of things, can create audio files for you and can pass along the audio files here and you can listen
to these files. I have several categories. So most things I've listened to, it goes to history once you listen. And these are some podcasts generated by actually Gemini Notebooks, previously known as Notebook LM. And so these are,
my model didn't make them, but my model... sent these to Gemini Notebook, created the podcast and then pushed them to my app. But then I have also day plan. So it can look at my day. And like this was for today. It's actually mentioning ODSC podcast was on my
calendar. So it is aware of that and my other things happening. You can have it look at your emails. I stopped doing that. That was too much. News is the one that I, let me try to find. Okay, this is the one. And by the way, you can use free open
weight models, which is this one based on. So the quality is not that great, but it's free. I have an old laptop sitting in my house. That is the one that is running these models. So my laptop actually is not doing anything. Or you could use something like 11 Labs. Some of the audio stuff I publish or
publish to myself is via 11 Labs. Much higher quality. But let me play and see. Let me know if you can hear. Okay. A note before this brief, the audio quality check flagged
dead air. A man in Melbourne asked his AI assistant to move him up a gym waitlist and it canceled a stranger's booking to do it.
First, the
gym,
the ABC in Australia. Okay, so you can, and then if I go maybe show you something higher quality, this is an open weight model, the pretty powerful multi-billion parameter open weight model. but you can get higher quality if you pay for it.
These ones are Gemini notebook. So these are much higher quality. We
are tackling a pretty massive question today. One that is fundamentally reshaping how we interact with technology. Oh, absolutely. And with each other. Yeah, exactly.
So our focus for this deep
dive is... Yeah, the Gemini Notebook is the podcast. I love it. You know, the voice of, the male voice, I recognize. He's in LA. His name is Leo Laporte, and he must have figured out some license agreement with Google.
Interesting.
Yeah, he's a guy that I used to listen to back in the 90s, like on a radio show. He would have a radio show. They called him the tech guy. And that was his brand back in. And he had a syndicated radio show. So when I first heard Gemini or the podcast when
Gemini came out, right, or, you know, when Notebook LM came out, like, man, that voice sounds so familiar. I'm like, oh, that's Leo Laporte. That's the tech guy. Anyway. When you did this, when you built this out, did you use AI Studio to like API endpoints from Google AI
Studio? Or does Gemini Notebook now have endpoints that you can access directly?
So I'm not sure if I can. I mean, this is a personal use. So the app itself gets populated with whatever your AI agent is doing. So this is not what the app itself is doing. This is what... My computer is doing the backend and yours could do anything that you directed to do. But
Google has stopped supporting the API for notebook-lm starting May this year. There is a backdoor. There is a library called notebook-lm-py. And it's the most reliable library
that I have used that library to build it. So the idea here is my cloud code agent has access to my meeting notes. It knows where my head is at and any given week or any given day. And based
on that, it will go do research. And it has a list of journals that I want it to find very, very recent papers that are published. Downloads the PDF. If it can't, it will skip it. I wanted the full PDF. It reads the paper. It
reads the main references of the paper that the paper's theory is based on that. It downloads those as well, submits them to Gemini Notebook. creates a podcast and then generates a, if I click on it, generates
a summary for me so I can see if I want to listen to or not. And then it has the actual references in the end somehow. Yeah. So it is also putting this URL here because I have a podcast channel. This is, I'm the only listener. It's not
public. So it also gets populated somewhere else. I can access it via my podcast app.
Man, this is some great work, Mohamed. This is great, great work. I really love this. Thank you. We don't have much time left, but let me ask you this. What was the biggest challenge in building the debriefs piece? And before you even
answer that, I love that you, when you're bringing in a paper, and I'm going to start doing this based on what you're saying or based on what you just said. When you bring in a paper, you're bringing in also some of the main sources, some of the main citations from that paper,
right? And that rounds it out. I love that because it provides more context, more extremely relevant context. I love that. When I read a paper via AI, you know, I do it more manual. Like I'll use, you know, Notebook LM or, you know, Gemini
Notebook now. But I've always been the one to just let me look at this paper, read it, summarize it, let's interact about it. But what I've not done yet is looked at the paper first or built an app to do it or a script or a schedule, whatever. It doesn't matter
now. But to look at the top citations and bring those in. So that's your professorial background talking to me and saying, Jerry, get your act together. So that's how I'm going to take it. But I love that. I really love that.
Yeah. Talk to me about the challenges. Like, what was the big challenge with this one?
So one quick comment. The other thing with this method you can do is that your Gemini notebook wouldn't know which paper to emphasize. So my cloud code agent writes the prompt for Gemini notebook. And it will
say, this is the paper I want you to emphasize. These are the pillars I want you to build on. So it wouldn't go and talk about all of those papers. Otherwise, you know, the paper you're interested in will take four minutes and then, you know, another 15 minutes would be spent on other things.
the biggest challenge here is to and this takes try and error and this is the part i didn't want to do in the app for everyone because your use case is going to be different than my use case is how natural the voice is do you
actually want to listen to it and for me it's been taken about a week or 10 days try an error i'm now spending more tokens for a script generation and I use Fable and I use a humanizer
skill and that part is being done by Fable. And then for the other parts, I have other agents that are cheaper, in some cases, Sonnet or even Haiku or just like searching. But the script itself and then inserting emotions, inserting
pauses. I have another pipeline that it gives me the news for five minutes and part of it is positive news because The world is, it feels like the world is burning at all time. You look up the news apps. So I have an
agent that looks for positive news in science, about nature, about travel, things I care about, animals. And it talks about it, besides before AI news. And then I have two... podcasts, they discuss the
news and they have their own opinion. So that's opinion piece. It's really hard to build something that is natural. My model is getting better now. It's not eerie. I can actually listen to it, but it needs, it has a lot of room for improvement. I've been trying to simulate
Gemini notebooks, but they've done a really good job. And I say one more thing for me, again, I wanted to make some distance between myself and my computer use. I am running a half marathon in a month and a half. Involuntarily, my sister
has signed me up. So I'm training for it, which is the best thing she's done for me, I would say, outside of being my wonderful sister. I've signed up for a gym. I'm going to the gym four or five times a day. It's half an hour round trip to get
there. And I spent two, two and a half hours at the gym. And a lot of that time on the treadmill, or I also like to run outside in the woods. And I go for an hour, an hour and a half. a lot of time that I kind of feel like the time
I'm missing, even though I understand I need to, I don't have to be learning all the time. But this way, while I'm driving at least, or some of the time I'm on the treadmill, because before I switch to music, I have something to listen to that I can catch up, right?
It makes me productive while I'm not behind my computer and I'm doing something else or I'm doing the dishes, et cetera. So that was my main motivation, but it takes time for the audio to become natural. And six months from now, the open weight models are going to
be much better than today, right? These are the worst models that we have to handle. Correct. They're only getting better.
Yeah. This is the worst it'll ever be, right? It's always going to get better. I love that you have involuntarily signed up for a half marathon. That's great. As you know, you know, I'm an endurance athlete and I do a lot of endurance and kind of extreme stuff. I think I told
you a few weeks back, maybe I didn't tell you this, but a few weeks back, I swam 10 miles. I did a 10 mile swim.
Wow. I love that. Which is
crazy. So I live on a bay. And so I'm able to swim basically long, like round laps. Basically, I did two mile loops around the bay. And it was pretty wild, pretty intense. Anyway,
so I can appreciate the involuntary efforts. to work out because the hack that I have to do, Muhammad, is not all the time, but many times, especially in the winter when I have to go to the pool or the gym or whatever, sometimes it's, okay, I'm not going to go
to the gym. I'm just going to get out of bed. Okay. I'm not going to go to the car. I'm just going to go to the door. I'm like, I'm not going to turn on the car. I'm just going to sit in it, right? Like I just kind of do these little hacks to get
me one step further. And then let's say I'm at the pool. Okay, I'm not going to jump into the cold water. I'm just going to stand in front of it just to kind of get me there. And so I can appreciate that. For me, I have this love-hate relationship with
like trying to learn while I do something else. Some of my friends, and you're one of them, are very good at being able to do that. I have such a hard time doing that. I have to listen to music or nothing. It's really hard for me to take that
part of my brain and kind of focus while I'm... It's just hard. It's just very hard. And maybe there's a way to do it or there's a technique that you and I can talk about another time. But I appreciate the idea because when you're doing something physical and you're in a
pattern... why not use your mental capacity to whatever, catch up, learn, build what you need to build, you know, in your mind, build the mental models, whatever you're working on. So this is great. Like this is a great way of looking at that and having it always available to you. That's, you know,
cause it's on your phone. Anyway, that's my two cents on that, but I love it. Muhammad, honestly, we could do like a long form on this, like in talk for another couple of hours, I'm sure. But man. So yeah, so to the audience, right? Like, you know, this is the
ODSC AI podcast. Mohamed is my first guest that I've interviewed on a podcast. This is my first guest hosting of a podcast. So I'm very excited about that. I'm very excited to have spoken to Mohamed about his stuff
today and just AI in general. And Mohamed, I'm thankful that we met each other and we're friends and we're able to talk this stuff out. Anything else you want to talk about or say, like before we sign off and talk another time?
Okay. First of all, I should say I didn't realize 75 minutes has gone by and I just felt like a catching up with you and so easy to chat with you and learn from you, Jerry. Thank you again for having me. I, the last thing I
want to say is I'm trying to spread as much possible to encourage people use AI to do things that weren't previously possible. And there is a lot that we can do. I don't appreciate the
huge amount of effort, cost-saving efforts that companies are undertaking and funding and trying to replicate the jobs that are being done. There is value there, but the harm that is coming out of that is potentially
more. But there are many, many areas, especially in medicine, healthcare. in education, in mental health, where AI can be used in a way that previously not possible and make the world more
equitable and more accessible for people. I would love us to go that direction as opposed to killing all the jobs and making companies make more money. And that's a scenario that we should avoid.
Man, that's a whole thing for another conversation. I'm so aligned with you on that. You know, people are more important than ever, right? And interacting with each other, right? Even if it's through Zoom or virtually, so much better than not interacting.
Right. And certainly just being physically present is obviously the best. There's something you can't emulate that even on a Zoom or you just can't emulate that. So I really appreciate your thoughts on that and the drive to move in that direction. Awesome, Mohamed.
Thanks. Excited for you. Excited for your projects. And we'll talk soon. And with that, we'll sign off for now.
Thank you so much. You have a wonderful day, Jerry.
Thanks, Mohamed. You too. Catch you later. See you. Bye.
See you. This episode is
sponsored by ODSCAI West, the premier AI builders conference coming up this October 27th to 29th in San Francisco and virtually. Learn more at odsc.ai slash west and use the code podcast for an
exclusive 10% discount. Supporting our podcast by subscribing not only helps our small dedicated team, but also unlocks exclusive benefits for you. Your engagement directly contributes to the growth and success of
our community. Please subscribe now and don't miss out on the next enlightening episode.